so Allison tell me a little bit about
working with Megan it was I'm not going
to say too much because I don't want to
like spoil
who Megan is and how she comes to be
because I think it's the most fun if you
just start in the theater and you're
like oh that's just Megan that said
it was fascinating I learned a lot I
think we all did it was very challenging
um multifaceted approach I think it took
teamwork from like every single corner
of our crew
um
that said it was something I will never
forget and an experience that I doubt I
will ever have again
anything remotely like it because it was
such a hybrid
kind of endeavor was it creepy yes the
creepier moments I think were the ones
where we weren't actually shooting so
like between cut and act the next action
either while we were doing a scene
together or even just during a break
when she was
not working
um very eerie just because I think she's
so alive to me like she seems so real
um that even when she's not talking or
doing anything it's so easy to just
project that onto her to imagine that
she's just gonna start strike up a
conversation with you and that element
of it's added a real sense of like
eeriness to being around her
deeply Eerie did she ever talk to you
during those breaks if I said yes your
next call should be to someone who's
gonna take good loving care of me and
make sure I'm okay um no she never did
um I I'm happy to report I have most of
my marbles you were an executive
producer on this
um what did that entail for you how did
that how did you juggle that with being
an actor on that I love I really loved
it it was my first time officially being
an executive producer on a movie I've
worked on I have always been super
involved in the things that I work on
it's just sort of my nature I'm Type A
what can I say so like from the script
to even the edit of the movie to the way
it's promoted and all of it I like to be
involved in all of it I find it
fascinating
um and so with this one I just
officially got to I like got to be on
the email distributions of like we're
trying to clear these toys for gemma's
shelf and like we can't get any toys
from this company but these are stuck in
customs in Japan and we can't get them
out you know I like love knowing all of
that at lunch every day we had a
production meeting and so I'd be Gemma
for like you know 10 hours and then we'd
break for lunch and I'd be the executive
producer and we'd talk about like the
rest of the day and the schedule going
forward and stuff and how we're gonna
achieve all this stuff or like such and
such after can't come in anymore we have
to recap whatever the logistics and then
go back into being Gemma I just loved I
loved it all and I'm loving
um The Experience out of like promoting
it and and delivering Megan to the world
and the marketing and and I'm not in
charge of any of it the the great joy is
being able to work with people who are
and learn from all the experts and like
the Geniuses who come up with these
trailers and who come up with the
marketing campaigns it's it's just so
much fun I really I found that it like
deepened my experience as an actor
because it allowed my investment to be
like as deep as I always wanted to be I
was able to just feel like I had kind of
a 360 point of view on what was going on
do you plan on producing more yes I
would love to it's gonna be hard to go
back I'm currently shooting something
where I'm not producing it and it's so
hard to not be like wanting to know
everything that's going on and it's just
an instinct that I have I don't know
maybe from being like doing jobs on sets
when I was growing up like PA and stuff
like that I like just knowing what's
happening and when I get to officially
know what's happening it definitely
makes me less sheepish about asking
those questions I feel like I'm entitled
to the answer yeah instead of just like
sneaking around exactly but it's also
the stuff I want to know is so unsexy
it's just like logistical information
about how the shoot's going and I'm just
like titillated by it I'm like you know
you know what does this do to our board
are we gonna have to add days you know
everyone's like oh my God if I were
responsible for paying for it these
things would be terrifying but it's just
interesting from my POV